that that's why uh the beer knuckle MMA
does it right because when you're trying
to get a promotion off the ground you
got to get people to T it's tough enough
there's so much content out there's so
much to compete with so you can't say
this is only if you pay
$50 because most casual fans like I
don't know who that is I don't pay for
that so you have people invested in the
first place pck MMA goes we're going to
give it to you tell us if you like it
then eventually down the road if these
guys become big stars or if you guys
want to watch them then maybe you pay
for it but right now just tell us what
you think of the product millions of
views across social media millions of
views now can you imagine if they went
nope it's a 100 bucks all right all
right here's 3,000 weirdos they're going
to pay for this thing because we have
nothing going
on